that is crazy bruh
[Music]
so we're going to play the king's indian
we're going to play the kings indian
which we've been kind of focused on
throughout the speedrun because it's the
opening that i play i also think it's a
very instructive opening
and um i i hopefully have done a halfway
good job of explaining
the sort of basic tenets of the king's
indian
now do you guys remember what the what
the main move here is
this looks like a blunder of a pawn but
as i've explained previously this
actually is the main move
it does not blunder upon because there's
a tactical reason behind it the move is
e5
let's hope he doesn't take um i i don't
like playing against the exchange now
i'm going to go for a structure
that i have gone for before i'm going to
take on d4
and the way to understand this is i've
explained previously right white's got
the space advantage what white's got
this bind on my center but
i have the ability to immediately and
frontally attack white spawns how
and i also have a secondary ability
and the secondary ability is to prepare
a pawn breakthrough
so this is kind of like the morocci vine
it's not literally the morose bite it's
kind of like the merotzy mind
now what pawn breakthrough can i prepare
and how can i prepare it
it's when you when you scour the board
for breakthroughs you you should see the
d5 is the idea that we want to prepare
but we can't go d5 immediately that
obviously blotters upon so we just
prepare it with c6 yeah that's all there
is to it
this is the theory yep so d5 he takes
and goes c5 that's the theoretical line
let's see if he knows it he does
a c5 is the move and now we simply want
to develop our knight
this is still theory as far as i
remember now after he castles
we want to increase the pressure on this
knight
right we have our knight pressuring his
knight and we actually want to make him
take our knight i'll explain that after
the game
uh and i'll explain the point of c5 as
well um
but how do we increase the pressure on
his knight how do we turn that volume
dial up
up um knight h5 yeah well it's not crazy
right knight h5 attacks the knight on d4
and where can this knight potentially go
well this knight can potentially go to
f4
which is a really nice square right so
you're killing two birds with one stone
and i like these positions knight b5 is
i think the best move
so actually let's go knight f4 i don't
see a reason not to
and now we can continue increasing the
pressure on the king's side how
how can we continue increasing the king
side pressure
so we have our knight here it's it's
already sort of pressuring g2
and now we can try to go queen g5 and
really turn the heat up
on the king side i don't see a reason
not to do that
uh and you know black is already white
is already in trouble i think because
we're threatening checkmate we're also
threatening a potential check on h3
people should see that because the pawn
is pinned to the king
and uh he's got a lot to take care of
here okay so
what should which of the moves should we
play here we obviously can't
jump over the pawn and deliver the
checkmate
but a move like g3 should set your alarm
bells ringing immediately
because um because it creates so many
weaknesses on the king side now should
we take the bishop
should we take the bishop
we okay again i i trick a lot of people
by asking that but we absolutely should
because by taking the bishop we are
creating very big weaknesses in his
position in particular you guys should
notice uh this e3 square let's take on
z4 once
simplifying the position and now we win
the game with what move
yeah we win the game with queen e3
because we simply win the night
and not only do we win the night we can
take it with the bishop or the queen
all right we're going to take it with
the bishop because we're also paving the
way for the queen to come to f2 with
absolutely devastating effect that is
the power of the king's indian when it
is played well
okay so
that is a relatively good king's indian
win
now he played what's called the
glitterage system that's bishop e3
and um f3 c6 now another good reason
that we play c6
is that this bishop on e3 is undefended
so if he castles
then uh then we play d5 and he can't
take on d5 with this pawn because the
bishop hangs
and if he takes with the c pawn then we
actually can play knight takes c5 this
is my game against robert hess from 2012
over the board
this is a line and this is
very bad for white for basically the
same reason
as in the game his knight on d4 loses
its support and
this just looks pretty darn ugly for
white
so he goes bishop f2 which is the
correct move he drops the bishop away
from the square where it was
x-rayed by the rook d5 takes take c
final what is the point of c5
the point of c5 is essentially to keep
the position closed
down number one and also this knight on
d4 remains
sort of robust as a blockader if you
don't play c5 let's say if you just
castle
then black has the potential of opening
the position up and when the position
opens up the knight on d4 kind of
loses its value the knight on d4 its
value comes from the fact that it
blockades the pawn on d5 if this pawn is
gone
then the knight is just sort of another
piece if that makes sense so knight c6
is correct castles and now knight h1 now
here's the moment where he went wrong
um and actually no no here is the motor
actually the move is not to castle and
in this position he has to well actually
he has to stop knight f4
if he lets me go knight f4 that knight
is devastating because it pressures the
bishop
it creates the possibility of queen g5
there's just too much
stuff that that goes on there so how
does he stop
knight f4 but without weakening his
position you don't want to go here
you do not want to go here because that
weakens so many of these squares around
the king side
what should white do here instead queen
d2 is correct nice job
orange queen d2 is absolutely right good
job now bishop a lot of your bishop e3
blunders the bishop
bishop g3 remember there's a knight on
d4
that blood is the knight so you you you
have to keep the bishop here where it
controls the knight there's a lot to
take care of here
we need to is the move so
knight cb5 he's just underestimating the
danger and at this point he's already in
big trouble
he's already in big trouble because this
is not easy to defend against
it's very much not easy to defend
against and again if he plays a move
like bishop g3
and he says get out of here then you you
might notice
that the knight on d4 is not under
protection what does black do in this
position to win the game
what does black do in this position in
the game you notice that the knight
guards the bishop
but the great thing about the king's
indian bishop the knight can be captured
you take the knight here
not the bishop but the knight because
the bishop on e2 loses its support and
you can potentially also lose your queen
so that just is game over rookie one
queen g5 and he's already busted
uh if he plays bishop f1 then we go
knight h3 and knight takes f2 and we win
the queen
so i don't see a defense for him at this
point
literally everything loses here so this
is why
why these positions are so fun i mean
they're open
and and everything seems to win so it's
very hard to play this with white
unless white is extremely well prepared
that's why you want to be careful about
which positions you go into
yeah that's all there is to it so well
h4 doesn't
okay so h4 in this position what would
get me cautious about this move or sorry
not not in this position but in this
position
wait in which position
i'm not sure which position you're
referring to
so oh why do we want him to take so if
he takes on c6
if he takes on c6 the reason this is
good for black there's two
main reasons this trade is good for
blind when you are evaluating traits
uh don't overthink it you have to
compare it before and after you know
those commercials before and after hair
treatment you know before they and it
always looks like it's a different
person
like literally the person before is the
most miserable human being on earth and
then after he's like the ceo of 18
companies
but you got to do the same thing um it
strengthens the center right there's a
pawn that appeared on c6
there's a pawn on d5 that pawn is passed
and now it is a protected passed lawn
protected passports are good
the other thing it does is opens up the
b file who does the b file benefit
well it benefits the side that can
occupy it and exert pressure down the
people can white exert pressure down the
b file no obviously there's a pawn on b2
this is why it's called a semi-open file
because only one side can benefit from
that file that would be black
you can put a rook on v8 and exert
pressure on b2
that's all there is to it right uh
that's why we want them to take we still
want them to take that would be the
same exact thing basically um
yeah i know there's a lot of question
well knight c2 doesn't actually help
prevent knight f4
well the light squared bishop is sort of
held in reserve yeah knight h5
is very very common idea in the king's
indian
um why didn't you want him to take in
the beginning well i just don't like
playing against the exchange variation
the exchange variation
forces an endgame exchange variation
forces an endgame
and that's a very early stage to force
in that game i remind you guys that if
flight takes on e5 with the pawn with
the knight
then we should notice that the bishop is
x-raying this knight the knight is
undefended
knight takes e4 wins back the pawn with
interest
and uh black is actually slightly better
in this position without this the king's
indian literally would not
work at all so this this is like
important
okay all right um so that's that game
any questions any last questions
okay let's play one last one and then i
might call it a knight
really appreciate everybody's support of
course okay let's go e4 this time
let's go e4 this time and a karo khan
so the line that i've been playing
almost exclusively let's play the narrow
con
queen f3 is the nereidski card gun this
is an opening that i have been playing
almost exclusively
um against the car con for like a year
in blitz
and um it's an opening that contains a
lot of traps and one of them actually
happens here we don't actually move the
knight
so white black attacks tonight what does
white do here
to not move the knight like what other
move does white have here
yeah it's bishop c4 so you attack f7 and
knight f6 is a mistake here
knight f6 in this position is a mistake
he's got to play e6 and he actually
plays it correctly
now we go back to e2 basically we get
this really interesting pawn structure
right
where okay it's like this pawn structure
occurs in other openings but what we're
basically going to try to do
is we're going to shift this queen why
are we going to shift the screen because
we need to develop the knight
and we want to develop the knight to f3
so that it attacks d4
where do you guys think we should put
our queen on f3 like what would be a
nice spot to park it on
so d3 is kind of awkward because then we
would not be able to develop this bishop
okay i know you guys are thinking about
attacking the pawn but remember black
can just play c5 and he can easily
defend the pawn
in fact he does exactly that um so in
fact i'm actually going to play the move
d3 first
yeah queen g3 queen g3 is where we want
to park our queen so that it exerts
pressure on the pawn the bishop on f8
cannot move
um and he's got to play the move g6 in
order to
liberate the bishop and that's kind of a
weakening move
then we can play the move knight f3 now
what move can we play first
before playing knight f3 if we wanted to
grab some more space on the queen side
what move yeah so we could consider
playing f4 now the drawback of that move
is that it would kind of block in the
bishop and in this game
in this game um but on the other hand it
would really help us expand on the queen
sides king side so
let's procrastinate let's procrastinate
let's first develop our bishop let's see
where he puts his knight
and if he puts his knight on g6 okay
let's go f4 why not
let's go four and then we're gonna
develop the knight behind the pawn
of course he can trade queens with queen
h4 but i don't really mind an end game
here we've got more space
white is okay so you guys have five now
the obvious immediate question we ask
ourselves when we
face a move like this is do we need to
react to this do is he actually
threatening anything specific
and do we benefit from taking on f5
we actually kind of do and i want
somebody to tell me
in what way we benefit from taking on f5
this is a subtle observation
now the way that we benefit from taking
on f5 is that he will not be
able to castle he will not yes so not
only do we open the e file
and we're going to castle and quickly
put a rook anyone but he will not be
able to castle
uh even if he gets his bishop out this
bishop as long as the bishop is on c4 it
covers the castle
square he can try to castle long but
he's a long way away from doing that
because he hasn't developed the c8
bishop yet
okay so let's let's bring our knight out
first
and then we're going to very quickly put
a rook on e1 and maybe knight g5 comes
i'm telling you this line of the karo
khan is super dangerous and
okay obviously let's get our rook over
to e1
okay whoa and now what what do we do now
now the attack literally plays itself we
consult all of our pieces okay which
pieces can we activate
and we see a very simple move knight g5
of course getting to f7 if he goes rook
cafe then knight takes h7 wins the game
and he just resigns this is over i mean
that f7 is a totally devastating threat
and uh that is why this line is very
dangerous there's a lot of traps like
this in the narrow con
um and i don't like playing it because
the emphasis of the speedrun is not on
winning with traps
but it's actually kind of a legitimate
opening it's been adopted by a lot of
other gm's
i think it's called a goldman variation
formally
so queen f3
now the move queen f3 let me tell you a
little bit about its history
um this is a very unorthodox move
obviously because
uh the knight belongs on f3 you're
literally putting the queen on a square
where the knight belongs
it's gotten very popular recently it was
played
by vasily smith love world champion from
the soviet union for the first time in
1950
so russians were the first like five or
six people to actually play this line
uh which is kind of cool i guess it's uh
symbolic right 1950
smith's love against floor uh floor was
uh
oh it was played in the candidates
tournament so it was played in a really
high stakes event for the first time by
vasily smith
these guys are pretty good now what is
the main trap
of this line the main trap black plays
knight f6 most of the time here
while this is not a mistake it actually
can lead to very quick victory
i have won me i've been moro with this
line what i'm about to show you and i
have beaten
countless players with this line here
you go
e5 the knight drops back to d7
okay white needs to defend this pawn how
does white defend this pawn
well obviously well 96 because then he
just takes
e6 is interesting but d4 now
what is the usual way in which black
undermines
this pawn chain like how in the french
how do you guys
you guys know this move right how ryan
khc priming thank you
c5 c5 but but but he can't believe c5
yet did it he can't play c5 yet because
the pawn on t5 will hang
so e6 is what everybody plays and now
white makes a very innocent looking move
knight h3
ah big deal c5 and people think that
they're better here because normally in
these positions white wants to play c3
and white wants to defend the pawn on d4
that's sort of
standard practice but black is losing
here
losing knight g5
but white is winning because after queen
e7 and do you guys want me to tell you
how many times
i have had this happen in my chess
career
i see my game against cecaro in the
slime at the very least
um so hikaru has fallen into this among
other people because the move knight to
b5
wins the game white is winning
because there is no defense against
these two threats
there is simply no resources that black
can allocate
to defend against these two horrific
horrific moves
black loses a ton of pieces a lot of
people go f6 here
now you go knight c7 check
king d8 knight g takes e6 check
it's basically checkmate black has to
give his queen up and the game is over
so this line is one of the appeals of
the of the narrow con
but we can also see in uh this game does
anybody
want to venture a guess as to why knight
f6
is actually inaccurate here
this is really cool this is really
really cool stuff
yeah e5 now watch what happens e5 d
takes e3
okay he takes the knight we take his
knight you might look at this position
and say well wait a second
uh black can win a pawn black can win a
pawn black can play
c takes d2 check okay it's check we have
to take
and now black can play he takes f6 but
look at the development that white has
and white combines this development with
castling and all of a sudden
black is in huge trouble he's completely
undeveloped
his queen is under attack his king is on
castles the bishop on c4
has ideas of sacrificing himself on f7
this is like
incredibly hard to play for black black
is already worse
i had this happen in a processly game i
botched it but i was basically winning
right out of the opening
and um this stuff is really dangerous so
his move e6 is actually correct but
my opponent went really wrong i think at
at this point after he goes knight g6 i
mean i think i would go g6
i think not developing this bishop for a
very long period of time is not a good
idea
like you have to get take care of that
bishop
and uh then you have to castle quickly
because the way that this happened
when i played f4 and still bishop e7
here
i would castle as quickly as possible
the move f5 is a very serious
misjudgment
and i think i've explained sufficiently
why this is a misjudgment the main
reason
is that even if black were to now
develop his bishop it's too late
he cannot castle literally it's illegal
and
the time that it takes to talk the king
away on the queen side
and it just doesn't come fast enough
okay because i'm going to put my rook on
e1 and i'm going to already be
threatening like a discovered check
that's totally devastating
so this k-98 is kind of caught in the
crossfire if that makes sense
so that i mean you can see how quickly
the attack proceeds and he resigns
here because the threat of knight f7 is
absolutely devastating
and if black defends against it by
putting a rook on a thing
why what move does white play here i
said this during the the game but
who can remind me of the move
i mean at like a 16 1700 level you can
absolutely yeah
boom boom there's no way to sustain
everything
okay well but i'm explaining that
william he resigned because
he has no way to defend against knight
f7
that's literally why he resigned i'm not
sure how else i could sort of explain it
if you have a specific proposed move uh
i'm happy to
analyze it um
you know what i'm saying but but
otherwise i you know it's the fact that
this threat is totally devastating
and um there is no other defense well 96
doesn't win the queen right 96 bishop
takes c6
so the specific threat here is
specifically knight at night f7
okay kb7 i suppose might be the best
move but now i can send you back with a
check
and um if you go to this side of the
board
then you walk right into the x-ray of
the rook this is going to be devastating
thank you flat dog 522
so this is crushing
well that's what i'm explaining right
bishop e6 here is crushing
all of these squares are just weak
there's too much attacking potential
that white has he trusted that i was
that i would be able to find these types
of moves
why can't queen take on f7 because the
f7 square is protected by the bishop so
in the event of let's say a random move
then we just take the queen with our
bishop we recapture it with our bishop
okay um does that make sense
could he have prevented him no literally
he is losing at this point i think that
his last chance to do something
maybe at this position he could have
probably gone i don't know king fa maybe
but still knight g5 is really really
devastating because this threat is
horrible
so yeah black has to castle asap uh it
really doesn't matter which rook we use
i just think this creates a more elegant
effect
well rook f8 we take on before again
there's too many
avenues of threats here you guys are
defending against one and allowing
another so
yeah maybe queen e7 i don't want to get
too detailed here but the bottom line is
clearly white's got the big initiative
clearly white's got the big initiative
and
it's it's incredibly hard to defend
against this stuff if that makes sense
all right i guess we can do one more i
guess we can do one more
okay matilda we're playing the same guy
okay um let's play a sicilian let's go
back to an accelerated dragon which
oh my god proper 25 after everything
that happened this morning
wow thank you proper 25
holy smokes oh distracting me from the
game i see what you're doing now i see
what you're doing now
damn girl now what what do we take the
bishop with here
and we actually have had a game like
this before
which way do we take the bishop we
so actually most people think b takes
but we actually take with the d pawn as
i've explained previously
and there are several reasons for this
it's complicated but
first of all we're opening the bishop
and that's
uh that's a pretty important thing also
we're sort of increasing our control
over the d
file well thank you prophet you are
very sweet and in order to increase our
control over the d4 square specifically
uh the move that we play here is e5
which is a move that confused a lot of
people the last time we played it
because it seems to block in the bishop
and i totally get that
uh but i'll sort of put this into
context after the game remember the
expression
bad bishops defend good pawns that is a
very important expression
and that expression helps us understand
why this move is justified so let's go
a5 let's stop him
from expanding on the queen side now we
want to develop this knight to e7 we
don't want to put it on f6 because that
would just blunder the pawn
okay so i'm going to do the same thing i
did in the previous game we go queen to
c7 to defend the pawn on e5
and this there's a certain kings indiana
component to this game
in that what is black's main idea here
what is one of black's main ideas here
how are we going to attack the king side
okay b4 is actually a really really
strong move
yeah so we want to play f5 but i
actually forgot about this idea he just
uh
well actually is it though okay so so
there's some interesting stuff that
happens so he breaks through with a5
um that's a pretty interesting idea i'm
not sure how good it is
i'm not sure how good it is i think it's
actually really really
good let me think
um yeah so the thing is if we attack the
knife we go b5
then he goes knight to b6 attacks the
rook and then he wins c5 so let's
actually
take the pawn let's take the pawn
and um black is probably worse here but
it's not clear
so now uh white is like
not threatening anything horrible white
has all of these little mini threats
it would be too early to play f5 because
our rooks are not connected
and our bishop has not developed so
let's develop our bishop
and let's see how he plays this but
basically we want to prioritize
completing our development here because
our position is kind of flimsy
if that makes sense and so we need to
complete the development as much as as
much as possible
thanks again prophet thanks trav man you
are
absolute beasts it's called the rosso
limo yeah so we're currently up upon he
can play bishop d6 and win the pawn back
but it's you know it's not um
it's not clear who benefits from that
because we also have a passport on a5
and stuff
so uh it's a very very complex position
lots to take into account here
uh let's see how he decides to play this
thank you um mq so i'm getting a lot of
christmas presents here early
and that is honestly awesome so
appreciate it
well bishop b6 we go queen b7 so
we're not trying to cling to our extra
pawn here thank you chris
g s y for the prime we're not trying to
cling to our extra fun what we're trying
to do is give away the pond with
interest
that is a a thing that i want people to
understand when you are up upon
one of the one of the benefits of being
up upon is that you can give it back
with interest you can give it back
at the right moment uh and you can give
it back and gain something in return if
that makes sense and this is what we're
essentially trying to do here
so i would definitely prefer bishop d6
and bishop takes e5 here
he's burning a lot of clock trying to
find the best way to do this and i think
he's failed to do that because
he is attacking art rook where should we
put our rook
where should we put a rook
this is not a very complicated question
because
yeah we just go rook a6 we attack the
knight we are threatening to take it
radio math thank you for the two months
i appreciate it okay so he's done
something really weird here
right he just drops his knight's a4 he
doesn't recapture the pawn
now we can go about improving our
position so
what i don't like about this position is
this pin this pin is annoying me because
the knight can't move
let's get the rook out of the pin let's
also put it on a file where it x-rays
the queen
okay now um let's just go h6 create some
love for the king and also cover the g5
square
okay so now we need to find a way to
basically push his pieces away
from uh no problem okay we're no
problem at all yeah so like i may be
this is actually not so easy i see what
he's trying to do here f5 is
see i'll explain this after the game f5
our position is way too fragile to allow
for something like f5 and i'll sort of
flesh that out after the game
let's go king h7 here okay let's
preemptively
uh defend the h6 pawn so that if he
plays bishop e3 which he
does uh he's not attacking the pawn and
we actually have a tempo here to do what
we want to do
and what white is threatening here to go
knight c5
we move our rook away and he cripples
our pawn structure with knight takes e6
how can we preempt that yeah we can
consider
actually i really like weed c8 for
several reasons part of it
is that i support the bishop on e6 and
another part of it
is that you can definitely consider a
sack on h3 although
you know when we do sack on h3 we will
only have a queen in the attack
and that's a danger zone kind of thing
okay so he takes we take
okay bishop b6 okay rook db8 maybe
okay he wants to take this way but then
his bishop becomes
kind of trapped okay if we take on b6 by
the way he takes our rook so we have to
take
okay so let's try to trap his bishop
here and in order to trap his bishop
uh we need to make sure that the pawn on
b4 is safely protected how can we safely
protect that pawn
yeah we can go c5 we also incidentally
create the threat of knight c6
okay so he finds a really really good
move um
but hmm okay let's go queen to a6 let's
swing the queen around
let's first swing the queen around and
then we'll go knight c6
he potentially can tuck his bishop away
like this but let's see if he does that
yeah this is where these people have
actually become incredibly good
yeah he finds a way to get out of this
now he's attacking the pawn
now he's attacking the pawn we need to
defend it let's defend it with our queen
and then we can try to centralize our
knight with knight to d4
let's see if he allows us to do that
perhaps
okay well glad glad you have
so knight c4 doesn't actually work how
do we prepare an it4 ah but he wants
this
now let's go rookie let's let's occupy
the file let's occupy the file let's not
let him go rook a1
okay b3 or c so we could play b3 but
then he goes for b1
and then he attacks the pawn which is
not a pleasant outcome so let's ignore
this
let's ignore this and let's uh
let's try to double on the a file let's
try to double on the eightfold i'm gonna
have to play a little bit faster guys
because i'm very low on time so let's uh
let's play a little bit faster but what
i'm trying to do here
is jogging for position oh and blended
one
now this guy is like a absolute beast
this guy is an absolute monster um he's
he's playing like one here
i'm basically trying to jock you for a
position on the queen side i've actually
wanted a pawn here
he's refuted that flawlessly
and um this is getting very complicated
okay so that's another super annoying
move
yeah honestly he's completely outplayed
me here so
i'm just losing in this position well
not losing but now i'm going to try to
get my knight to e6
and i'm gonna try to get that knight
around to f4 ultimately no these guys
are like
insane honestly okay i'm gonna have to
play f6 to defend the pawn on e5
yeah i need to be focusing a little bit
but i mean i'm still winning most games
pretty
handily but some sometimes these guys
are like incredible
sometimes these guys are like absolutely
incredibly strong
not like 2 300. i'm not expecting them
to be weak but
you know i actually kind of have
forgotten how good these people are
so knight f6 is a really good move here
for example
the the problem is uh he he's he's just
too slow
he's he's taking like five seconds for a
move here
but he's finding absolute best moves
like every move
uh he's just gonna not probably i hope
not make it here
so we're going to get the knight to see
one and attack the spawn rook b oh my
god he might make me there
i think he might have had mate actually
okay we're gonna give him a check
okay here to stop the king's progression
let's get the night out out of the way
yeah okay so that wasn't great um again
to
give you guys a sense the accuracy in
this game very bad yeah my mind was bad
it was 92.6
for my opponent 74.2 for us
so not not one of my best games um but
you know really good play by my opponent
honestly
well again well let's not speculate um i
think he played like a gm but
but he played legitimately so he found
some incredibly strong ideas
all right so basically
okay no but his opening was incredibly
good so
basically this move b4 is super strong
and this is actually a very thematic
breakthrough in this line
well i would say this i think my
opponent played on a gm level throughout
the game not just
not just in the opening uh or not just
in the end of the game but
he outplayed me from a position where i
thought that black was close to winning
he found a way to get his bishop out so
it was really back and forth
so thematic thematic comes from the word
theme
and when i talk about a thematic idea
um i'm talking about an idea
that commonly occurs in this type of
position maybe not
specifically in this position although
i'm sure probably it has
but it occurs commonly in these types of
positions in fact i could make a
chess-based search as i'm peeing
i'm going to let chess base do its work
and i promise that i will find for you
guys
several grandmaster game examples of
exactly this concept
uh in in grand master games that's
really what i mean
from by thematic here is literally
uh dvora's 2440 falling into the same
exact
well kind of trap okay you guys can see
knight c4 okay he goes f6
and uh i played queen c7 in this exact
position
but f6 b4 aba5
and this is like literally the exact
same thing happens it's
it's semen but a different one um and
and he he crushes the guy he crushes the
guy
uh basically the whole queen side
explodes and he plays uh
a brilliant brilliant game i plays a
brilliant game okay
uh anyways i just okay now i know what
people are focusing on
i made a mistake choosing this guy not
the 500 others
um so i should have realized that
but basically that's one example of why
this is uh thematic
crucial mistake right
so you guys can see that this is
literally the same thing a takes before
a5
and um if c takes b4
then bishop takes b6 and bishop takes a5
the problem here
is that this pawn on b6 is the culprit
the pawn on b6 is a backward pawn
which means that if there is a white
pawn that gets to it
things start to collapse here and this
is exactly what happens if
b5 it's all good guys then knight b6 and
you attack the rook
and then bishop takes c5 comes and white
takes this pawn
black's position collapses completely i
hope that makes sense so i decided to
take but after bishop takes c5 thanks
for a good night with the tier one
um black is up upon answer for cha with
the two one
it's hard for me to like explain this
verbally but even though black is
currently up upon
my position is on the verge of
collapsing because white's got all these
moves
and all these other pawns are really
weak in fact
white is even threatening to take on
before and you can't take back because
the rook on 8 is hanging so a lot of
people were suggesting f5 but
you know this is like starting another
fire there's already so many fires
burning and you're starting another fire
in the center of the board
black will not be able to sustain this
move thank you the dead rooster for the
tier one
if that makes sense so for example
bishop takes v4 is good here
or bishop d6 and bishop takes e5 rooting
out the bishop
and um well i do a position search
basically
and so this position is super concerning
that's why i got my bishop out
and now my opponent played really
weirdly knight v6 is super weird
um i think bishop d6 is probably the
most sensible
and and then just taking on e5 i'm not
sure what white is better here but
um you know but but white restores
material equality and now the bishop
is not going to be good so
you know so that would have been good
but my opponent played this which
i mean i guess it made sense in the end
and um it's interesting but it keeps me
with an extra pawn now i go rook d8 he
goes rookie one
and now i miss the super five head
maneuver which i actually
saw but i thought that i wasn't in a
hurry and i should have been
now this bishop on e6 is a bit of a
problem piece it has no good like
roll it's not really doing anything it's
just sort of sitting there
and um we could have actually employed
it we could have actually led it to a
square where it's doing something
but it involves a really really nice
maneuver could somebody spot it
like seeing this is no easy task
really bishop c4 is right bishop c4
bishop b5
and then the bishop is putting pressure
on the knight and the reason that
matters is because if the knight ever
moves then a4 becomes a possibility
pushing that pawn
that pass spawn so this idea i saw but i
decided to play h6 first just improving
the position unfortunately he goes queen
c1
and now bishop c4 is no longer possible
because there's no more pin
okay and now he he starts out playing
bishop e3 is super good
vacating that square for the knight so
we drop the queen back
in order to defend the bishop but now he
takes and goes bishop b6
and amazingly after rook d8 rook a5 like
i thought i was trapping his bishop but
this knight d2 move is super annoying
this knight d2 move is super annoying he
gets his knight to c4
and the knight will support the bishop
and i didn't see a good way to do
to do to
travel i didn't see a good way to trap
the bishop
absolutely man awesome so basically
i didn't see a good way to trap the
bishop because the bishop has this
square
the bishop has this square and basically
uh
i played queen a6 this is the mistake i
should have kept the queen here gone
here
i saw i heard about that and
it's very important to be flexible i
didn't practice what i preached
i didn't practice what i preached and
what i preached
is that um you have to be very flexible
in the way that you think about certain
things
so for example okay you've come to terms
with the fact that you can't trap the
bishop right
the bishop is not going to get trapped
because it has this hiding square
okay that's not a problem let's go
knight t4 let's improve the position of
the knight
and maybe break through with b3 so
instead i stubbornly tried to pursue the
bishop
and my opponent got it to d6 now the
bishop is perfectly safe
and guess what now he gets his queen to
b2 and he can go c3 he starts breaking
through
and my position starts to collapse so i
accidentally blundered this pawn on top
of that
and um you know and okay guys but maybe
we can discuss the game
uh for now
so don't go chasing waterfalls exactly
i'll play that song afterward now i'm
down upon and my opponent played this
perfectly
i mean the end game was really bad for
me he outplayed me further
and uh it's all good and and rookie rook
v8 here would have been
absolutely devastating actually because
there is no defense against this mate
if if g5 then he takes f5 and he covers
the g6 square
so really my big mistake i think it's
somewhere in the opening i went wrong
but then not going bishop c4
and then like not being flexible being
very stubborn trying to pursue this
bishop
and letting my opponent you know
basically gain the upper hand over me
rather than just saying okay
i'm not going to trap the bishop i'm
just going to get my knight to a good
square
and uh you know come hell or high water
basically
[Music]
you